non mais regardez regardez ce spectacle
dès qu'on a le dos tourné au sinon tout
sur la balade d'automne alors je viens
collection n'a plus le droit des
affaires
vous allez avoir des problèmes je n'ai
pas mis les deux sous et les voilà voilà
une belle collecte à l'émission peut
commencer numéro 1 sans jamais prononcer
rimbaud kabila mais désormais la
personnalité la plus suivie sur tik tok
avec
144,3 millions d'abonnés c'est 500
milles de plus que l'américaine charlie
d'amelio son succès il le doit à ses
sketches dans lesquelles il moque des
vidéos d'astuces souvent absurde avec ce
geste devenu incontournable
turcot
bon j'avoue je connais pas
non c'est une blague il n'y a que lui
c'était pas acheter
un jeu digne sont tous en passant % non
et sinon c'est quoi d'origine turque bon
ce n'est pas grave moi c'est pas
marseillais
me suis sentie à la fois gêné à la fois
un peu exclu du groupe puisque j'étais
la seule personne à ne pas les
reconnaître l'année dernière le site de
classement humoristique topito place et
kevin en haut de l'échelle des prénoms
je le cite les plus connoté ceux à ne
pas donner à vos enfants et ensuite le
site décrit les kevin de la sorte en
disant que ce sont des beaufs en herbe
sincèrement dans le regard de la mère de
caroline tu joues tu dis
il est petit et quand l'une serait
beaucoup plus grand ça va pas lui plaire
la barge a trop beaucoup trop longue et
puis le costume bleu car l'une de test
les costumes bleus là ça fait un bond
qui fera là sa peine
je m'attendais pas à autant de dureté et
de
jugement comme ça
voilà surtout quand on tire les cartes
ec on dit il faut pas juger sur de
l'apparence kevin donc peut être un
frein dans la vie amoureuse est un frein
au site professionnel assez végal
visiblement un kevin à 10% à 30% de
chances en moins d'obtenir un poste qu
un arthur donc les deux députés prénommé
kevin ont réussi à déjouer le
déterminisme social et kevin fey faire a
déclaré qu'il représenterait je cite
tous les kevin de france il représentera
en tout kaehlin qui partagent cette
réunion ses opinions politiques ce
projet de loi pouvoir d'achat c'est la
réponse promise par l'exécutif à
l'inflation qui galope 5,5 pour cent en
moyenne pour 2010 avec de bonnes
nouvelles puisque de nombreuses
allocations vont être revalorisées de 4%
et ce sera rétroactif parce que la loi
doit passer en conseil des ministres ce
6 juillet mais dès le 1er juillet on
vous versera si elle est adoptée en
considérant dès le 1er juillet vous
verrez en france on n'a pas de pétrole
mais on a des idées de protection qu'ils
temporaire parce que l'inflation le pic
d'inflation est temporaire et qui doit
être le plus ciblé possible sur les
ménages qui en ont le plus besoin sur
les jeunes et qui en ont le plus besoin
sur les familles qui en ont le plus
besoin l'augmentation des appels de 3 5%
c'est une façon de répondre aux
difficultés de tous ces personnes
totalement dégonflé
et lâche
un géant désert muni d'un réacteur à
propulsion nucléaire est capable
d'accueillir cinq mille passagers avec
des prestations dignes d'une croisière
de luxe surtout digne d'un film de
science fiction car l'engin présentés
dans cette vidéo très visionner en ligne
n'est rien d'autre qu'une vue d'artiste
aucun projet de la sorte n'est en
production peu importe l'idée est
conspué à l'heure où chacun est appelé à
réduire sa consommation énergétique